This mussel is spurting babies!
Biologists at Cambridge University have just
discovered that females of this endangered
freshwater mussel species will move to shore,
attach themselves to the bank, then blast
a larva-filled stream of water a meter through
the air.
That’s 23 times their own body length, the
same as you spitting babies about 40 meters,
or 131 feet.
The larva in the jet then parasitically attach
to the gills of passing fish and grow into
juveniles.
No other species of mussel has been seen doing
this.
So best of luck with your survival of your
species, ya baby squirtin’ little freak.
Vsauce!
One story down, five to go.
This is Mind Blow!
Turn your phone into a makeshift fluorescent
microscope!
We owe much of what we know about cell and
tissue development in the human body to fluorescent
microscopes.
It produces clear, beautiful images of tiny
cells that help highlight and identify specific
molecules and tiny biological structures.
Well, a team of biologists at Winona State
University in Minnesota have just figured
out a way to use off-the-shelf components
to turn any smartphone into a fluorescence
microscope - for only about THIRTY BUCKS.
Called a glowscope, its made up of an LED
flashlight, theatre filters, and a smartphone.
This is an amazing tool for hands-on science
education.
They even posted full instructions to build
your own online so you can finally study those
zebrafish embryos you’ve got in your garage.
ATOMS CAN PLAY BASEBALL.
With chilled rubidium.
A team at the Korea Advanced Institute of
Science and Technology threw chilled rubidium
atoms a distance of 4.2 micrometers -- which
would be a full kilometer for a real baseball.
They dropped the temperature to 0° Kelvin
-- just above absolute zero -- and tossed
it into two optical traps generated by 800
nanometer lasers.
The atom pitcher wouldn’t sign with the
Yankees, let me tell ya that!
The rubidium “fastball” moved at 65 centimeters
per second, or 1.5 miles per hour.
But it’s not actually about replicating
baseball -- testing and refining this technology
can eventually make quantum computers millions
of times faster than what we have today.
Now for a very special Happy 4th Birthday
to RAID Shadow Legends!
The turn-based battle game with a focus on
collecting Champions.
I grew up getting about one video game a year
in the ‘80s so seeing these graphics on
my phone downloaded for free is insane.
There are over 650 unique Champions that you
can customize in billions of ways with new
Champions and updates every month.
And incredible boss battles.
I take a Conan The Barbarian philosophy when
it comes to playing RAID, R - Ravage your
enemies, A- Assault all bosses, I - Impale
online challengers, D - Destroy and hear their
lamentations.
And to celebrate RAID’s 4th Anniversary
there are dedicated offers, free gifts, promo
codes, Events, and a brand-new Fusion Event
where you can get your hands on an Anniversary-themed
Legendary Champion!
Use my link in the description or scan my
QR code to get amazing bonuses.
Like Epic Champion Kellan the Shrike and super
useful items.
Once you’re in-game after clicking on the
links, just enter Promo Code 4YEARSRAID for
4 Legendary Skill Tomes and much more.
So, just hit my link in the description or
scan my QR code and come find me under the
name Vsauce2Kevin.
And big thanks to Raid for sponsoring Vsauce2.
Feel sober instantly with a shot!
Someday, maybe.
Biochemists at the University of Texas have
discovered that an injection of Fibroblast
Growth Hormone 21, also known as FGF21, cured
mice of alcohol-induced dizziness and impairment.
They recovered from alcohol six times faster
than mice without it, and when scientists
gave the shot to mice who had passed out from
alcohol, they woke up twice as fast.
The hormone doesn’t actually get rid of
the alcohol in the subject’s bloodstream;
it just stops it from impacting their nervous
system - so you’re still drunk, you just
don’t feel drunk.
Researchers say their discovery could be useful
for treating loss of consciousness and impaired
mobility among people with acute alcohol poisoning.
But no word yet on when you’ll be able to
order one bourbon, one scotch and one FGF21.
The T-1000 Terminator begins with THIS SNAIL.
Engineers at Carnegie Mellon University in
Pittsburgh have created a breakthrough in
softbiotics - a flexible, self-healing, liquid-metal
filled organogel with metal-like conductivity,
that can support electrical motors and digital
electronics.
So far they’ve used this incredible advance
to create…this snail.
It may move slowly, but when researchers cut
the circuits that powered its locomotion,
the organogel healed itself and restored almost
70% of the lost power, making it the first
of a new generation of robots with integrated,
regenerating, sensing, movements - and probably
a desire to terminate snail John Connor.
Ancient Romans REALLY wanted this dead guy
to STAY DEAD.
The tomb of an Imperial Roman noble family
was recently excavated by archaeologists at
Catholic University Leuven and it contained
a body sealed with an unheard-of three separate
protections to stop them from coming back
from the dead.
First, the body was burned inside the tomb
and left there, which is extremely rare in
Roman burials.
Second, it was “nailed down” with dead
nails that had been intentionally bent and
disfigured, a known ancient charm against
evil magic.
Finally, they sealed him under a layer of
quicklime covered in heavy tiles, to stop
the body from rising again.
No Roman burial has ever been found with all
three of these ancient protections in one
place.
So let me know what YOU think this guy did
to earn unprecedented levels of zombie-proofing.
And now for a news report on the Nintendo
Entertainment System from 1988.
Should parents buy these games at all?
The National Coalition Against Television
Violence thinks they shouldn’t!
Because they say they’re bad for kids.
She doesn’t like it.
This girl’s mother doesn’t like the game.
Cause she thinks that you’re going brain
dead while you’re watching it.
Maybe you will be brain dead from staring
at this thing all the time?
No!